Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir !
Je suis ravi d’être là.
Je suis un neurologue.
On parle de neurologue
ce soir, j’ai l’impression.
Je suis un neurologue
et je m’occupe d’une unité
dédiée à des patients
qui présentent des troubles cognitifs -
mémoire, langage, troubles du
comportement - dans différents aspects,
en particulier dans le cadre
de pathologies neurodégénératives,
mais également de troubles
du neurodéveloppement
ou des personnes qui présentent
des lésions cérébrales focales,
inflammation ou traumatisme crânien.
Et ce soir, j’ai eu envie de vous parler
de deux des personnes
dont je me suis occupé.
Monsieur E.
Monsieur E. a 80 ans,
il vient à la consultation de la mémoire
car il a un problème de mémoire.
Il décrit que depuis quelques semaines,
quelques mois,
il a un peu de mal à retrouver
où il a mis ses lunettes.
Il décrit que parfois, il a du mal
à savoir où il a rangé ses papiers.
À part ça, pas grand-chose.
J’avoue que monsieur E. ne m’impressionne
pas beaucoup quand je le vois.
Premier contact, on a un contact
qui est sympathique, qui est agréable,
et sa plainte me paraît
relativement banale.
Il dit quand même que ça le gêne
dans sa vie quotidienne,
ces petits oublis qu’il n’avait pas avant.
Je rencontre un homme qui a eu
beaucoup de chance dans sa vie.
Monsieur E. eu la chance
de faire de grandes études.
Il a eu un poste de responsabilité.
Il y a eu diverses activités
sportives, intellectuelles.
Il a participé à des clubs.
Il a eu une vie plutôt
heureuse et stimulante.
Finalement, on va se quitter
à cette première consultation.
Je vais lui dire
que je ne suis pas inquiet pour lui,
qu’on ne va pas faire d’examens
complémentaires mais par contre,
comme il a une plainte
et qu’on fait toujours attention
quand les gens viennent nous voir
et qu’ils ont une plainte,
je le reverrai six mois plus tard.
Six mois plus tard, monsieur E. revient.
Il ne va pas bien.
Il s’est aggravé.
Il a du mal à se rappeler
ce qu’il a fait la veille.
Quand il prend sa voiture, des fois,
il se perd dans ses itinéraires.
On décide de faire un bilan
et on lui fait faire des examens
qui sont assez classiques.
C’est un test de mémoire très sophistiqué
pendant 2 h avec une neuropsychologue,
une IRM cérébrale qui va retrouver
une atrophie cérébrale qui est importante,
et une ponction lombaire,
examen classique pour déterminer
si les gens ont ou non
une maladie d’Alzheimer.
On va poser le diagnostic chez Monsieur E.
d’une maladie d’Alzheimer
à début tardif - il est déjà âgé.
On met en place plusieurs choses
que je ne détaille pas,
et je le revois trois mois,
puis six mois plus tard,
et c’est la dégringolade.
Monsieur E. va chaque fois
beaucoup moins bien
et deux ans plus tard,
cet homme ne peut plus être autonome
dans sa vie quotidienne.
Il a besoin d’être aidé.
Et puis quatre ans plus tard,
il ne peut plus rester à la maison.
L’histoire de Monsieur E.,
elle est un peu comme ça.
Pas grand-chose
ne se passe pendant des années
et quand il y a un petit truc
qui se met à ne pas aller,
les choses s’aggravent
de manière très rapide.
A présent, madame C.
Madame C. a 65 ans, elle vient
à la consultation de la mémoire,
car elle a un problème de langage.
Elle a du mal à trouver les mots,
mais aussi un problème de mémoire,
du mal à se rappeler
ce qu’elle a fait la veille.
Quand je vois cette dame,
je trouve que d’avoir d’emblée,
à 65 ans, un trouble de la mémoire
et un trouble du langage,
ce sont des signes
qui ne sont pas  très typiques
pour quelqu’un qui a cet âge-là.
Cette dame, on va lui faire faire
un bilan neuropsychologique,
une IRM, une ponction lombaire.
On va faire un diagnostic de maladie
d'Alzheimer de début plutôt précoce.
Cette dame, elle a eu moins
de chance dans sa vie
puisqu’elle a très vite quitté le collège
vers l’âge de quatorze ans,
parce qu’il avait fallu
travailler à l’usine.
Elle a travaillé toute sa vie à l’usine,
a eu une vie assez routinière.
Elle a quand même fait
pas mal de marche à pied
et a eu peu de contacts sociaux.
Elle n'a jamais eu d'enfants.
Cette dame, je vais la revoir
six mois plus tard après le diagnostic,
elle n’a pas bougé, à peu près pareil.
Elle s’est même améliorée
parce qu’on a mis en place quelque chose.
Six mois plus tard, la situation
est relativement stable.
Six mois plus tard,
elle s’est un tout petit peu aggravée
et en fait, elle a une maladie
qui évolue relativement lentement.
Voilà le profil évolutif
de la maladie de cette dame.
Ces deux personnes,
Madame C. et monsieur E.,
ils ont la même maladie.
En fait, la question scientifique
qui se pose,
c’est pourquoi une même attaque
d’une maladie neurodégénérative,
la maladie d’Alzheimer, va être
si différente entre deux individus.
Et une des façons
de répondre à cette question,
c’est de se poser la question
de ce qu'on appelle la réserve cognitive.
La réserve cognitive, c’est un concept
qui a été inventé il y a des années,
environ 20 ans,
par un chercheur américain
qui s’appelle Yakov Stern.
Ce professeur Stern,
il a expliqué plusieurs choses.
Globalement, la première chose,
c’est qu’il a appelé la Brain Reserve.
C’est la façon dont notre cerveau
est constitué.
Alors ça, on ne peut pas
y faire grand-chose.
Ce sont des facteurs
essentiellement génétiques,
la façon dont notre volume cérébral,
notre épaisseur de cortex,
notre profondeur des sillons cérébraux,
sont constitués.
Et puis il a inventé un concept,
qui a été repris par des dizaines
de recherches, des centaines d’articles,
qui est celui de la réserve cognitive.
Cette réserve cognitive,
il faut la comprendre
en trois parties spécifiques.
Il y a la première qui existe
avant l’âge de 25 ans.
Globalement, il faut se dire
que le cerveau est en maturation
jusqu’à l’âge de 25 ans.
Pour ceux qui ont passé cet âge,
après, c’est la dégénérescence.
Dommage.
Vous pouvez partir,
mais ce n’est pas fini pour vous.
J'ai des bonnes nouvelles quand même.
Donc jusqu’à 25 ans, le cerveau
peut gagner de la réserve,
un matelas cognitif dont on pourra
se servir plus tard, à son insu.
Cette réserve dépend essentiellement,
à 70%, du niveau d’éducation.
C’est un point qui est important.
Et donc l’idée de pouvoir favoriser
une éducation chez les enfants,
Et c’est évident que ces deux-là, ici,
ils n’ont pas eu
la même chance à la naissance.
Donc là, les inégalités sociales jouent
un rôle extrêmement important
sur cette réserve cognitive.
Derrière la réserve cognitive,
et donc l’éducation,
il y a bien sûr un emploi
avec des postes de responsabilité,
mais également
une activité physique régulière,
et on dit plutôt une activité sportive,
des loisirs, des stimulations sociales,
des stimulations cognitives,
un sommeil de qualité.
Et toutes ces activités ici permettent,
jusqu’à l’âge de 25 ans,
de se faire cette réserve
dont on pourrait avoir besoin
s’il y a un imprévu dans la vie.
On ne fait pas du sport
ou on ne va pas à l’école
au cas où ça aille
moins bien à 50 ans, à 60 ans,
mais en tout cas ça y contribue.
Entre 25 et 50 ans, cette réserve
peut augmenter de manière progressive.
Et puis ensuite, à partir de 50 ans,
il y a un truc déterminant
pour maintenir sa réserve cognitive,
c’est limiter les facteurs
de risque vasculaire.
Personne n’a quitté la pièce
pour aller voir son cardiologue !
Essentiellement, c’est contrôle
de l’hypertension artérielle avant tout,
le diabète, le cholestérol,
le tabac, le surpoids.
Mettre à distance les toxiques,
ça, on peut le faire
un peu plus jeune même.
Et le syndrome d’apnée du sommeil
qui est un point important
pour favoriser la réserve cognitive.
Tout au long de sa vie, en particulier
dans les 25 premières années,
cette réserve, on la construit.
Mais on peut la maintenir,
voire l’augmenter
et ne pas la perdre
en faisant attention à soi
avec toutes ces stimulations
et en limitant les lésions cérébrales
qui sont liées aux facteurs
de risque vasculaire.
Je vous montre ici, pour illustrer
ce propos de la réserve cognitive,
un article scientifique qui a été publié
par des collègues néerlandais
il y a deux ans,
qui montre en fait deux stades.
Vous voyez ici la courbe verte
qui correspond à des patients
qui ont un bas niveau d’éducation.
J’ai bien réfléchi avant de mettre
une dame avec un bas niveau d’éducation
et un homme avec un haut
niveau d'éducation.
Donc avant d’être attaqué, j’ai fait ça
parce que c’est comme ça qu’on voit
dans nos consultations aujourd’hui.
Les hommes sont allés à l’école
et les dames ont été moins favorisées.
Les 60 ans, c’est encore comme ça,
probablement, ça va changer.
En tout cas, on espère que ça va l’être
et que tout le monde va être à égalité.
Mais la réalité de nos consultations,
c’est encore celle-ci.
Donc une dame
avec un bas niveau d’éducation
et un homme avec un haut
niveau d’éducation,
ils ont ici récupéré les mêmes couleurs.
Et vous voyez ici
que dans le cerveau de ces gens,
il y a l’attaque
d’une pathologie neurodégénérative,
d’une protéine anormale qui se dépose,
qui s’appelle la protéine amyloïde.
Cette protéine s’accumule
pendant des mois et des années
avant le début des symptômes.
Et vous voyez que
le haut niveau d’éducation,
sa cognition, sa mémoire va rester stable.
Son cerveau va s’adapter
à l’attaque de cette protéinopathie,
de cette amyloïdopathie,
alors que le bas niveau d’éducation
qui a moins de réserve cognitive
va présenter un déclin cognitif
qui va s’installer
beaucoup plus précocement.
Et on sait, entre un haut
et un bas niveau d’éducation,
une haute réserve cognitive
et une basse réserve cognitive,
le délai peut être d’une différence
de dix ans de début des symptômes.
Donc c’est absolument… dix ans
sans être malade, c’est quand même mieux.
Quand la maladie a commencé,
ce qui est intéressant ici,
qui explique un peu mes courbes là,
c’est que le bas niveau d’éducation
va continuer sa maladie
qui va évoluer
de manière relativement lente,
alors qu’il y a une accélération
dans le haut niveau d’éducation
comme si la digue était plus haute,
mais une fois qu’elle cède,
la maladie évolue de manière très rapide.
Ici, mon propos est multiple.
La première chose,
il faut promouvoir l’éducation.
Ici, c'est relativement facile
avec cette assemblée.
La deuxième chose, c'est que tout au long
de sa vie, il faut protéger son cerveau.
Attention aux toxiques !
Attention, à partir de 50 ans,
aux facteurs de risque vasculaire,
en particulier
à l’hypertension artérielle.
Et puis le troisième point qui est
important, c’est mon dernier point,
c’est que, en fait, cette histoire,
c’est une histoire de triangulation
entre le dépôt d’une protéine amyloïde,
si on prend l’exemple
de la maladie d’Alzheimer,
la capacité de résistance qu’a le cerveau,
un peu à notre insu,
liée à cette réserve cognitive,
et puis des facteurs
qu’on ne maîtrise pas du tout,
qui sont beaucoup des facteurs génétiques.
Et pour un individu donné,
cette triangulation varie de manière
très particulière et très originale
et très singulière pour un individu.
On voit des gens avec
des hauts niveaux d’éducation
qui ont des maladies qui évoluent
doucement et inversement.
Donc tout n’est pas lié
à des réserves cognitives.
Il y a d’autres facteurs qui peuvent
jouer le jeu, mais dans nos vies,
pour se préparer, pour avoir un cerveau
qui est capable de s’adapter,
on a une tendance importante
à essayer de maintenir
ce haut niveau de réserve
avec ces différents points.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)